(rap music)
♪ Four and three and two and one
- Trey!
- Wassap!
Today is a new day. Cha-ching!
Looks like we're watching
The Apprentice All-Stars!
Good thing you chose left,
guess what the right was?
(laughs)
I just want to get in here,
Axe my body from
head to toe, and then
zen out!
- Zen out!
(thumps)
- There's no 'I' in Soulstice.
- But, there's--
- Well, yes, there is, yes.
I've actually been
trying to get them
to change it to a 'Y'.
There's a bloody (beep)
in your speech studio.
You know how when we have
sex, you tell me not to talk
so you can concentrate?
Which, I totally get it, but...
Want to see my impression
of a Picasso painting?
- Yes.
- Okay.
- I would love to.
(laughs)
- Just relax that
face, buddy, okay?
Relax that face.
Body By Trey dot biz! Cut out.
Oof, I stink.
(music)